so the victims of vladimir putin's
completely absurd decision to invade
ukraine are piling up and some of those
victims are russian and there is a an
incredible bit of news because it's so
predictable this was exactly what many
people started asking about when the
russian forces
dug in near chernobyl in ukraine
russian troops are suffering acute
radiation sickness after digging
trenches at chernobyl
several hundred russian troops
reportedly rushed to a special medical
facility in belarus after digging in
radioactive soil
in a forest near the infamous nuclear
plant
um this is not about the real victims or
the russians no no the the primary and
obvious real victims are all of the
ukrainians and the civilians and the
children and all of the different people
in ukraine who have suffered and been
killed at the hands of this
authoritarian madman but it's also a
reminder
putin is very much like trump and that
he really only cares about people to the
extent that they're useful to him and as
individuals these russian troops are not
really useful to him in terms of do they
get radiation poisoning where what are
we sending them into that doesn't matter
what matters is are they useful to me in
achieving my foreign policy goals and at
least for a period of time putin
believed that that was going to be
accomplished by sending troops in
including to places rife with radiation
now for people who don't know the
backstory about chernobyl chernobyl was
this nuclear disaster it was a nuclear
accident and it happened in 1986 at one
of the reactors at the chernobyl nuclear
power plant in ukraine and uh this is
considered the worst nuclear disaster in
history in terms of number of casualties
as well as in terms of the financial
cost and there's only been two
nuclear energy accidents in history
rated at a seven which is the highest
level of severity
on what's called the nuclear event scale
the other was the fukushima disaster in
japan a little over 10 years ago so
chernobyl and fukushima are the only two
level seven disasters and
um it is still an extremely radioactive
area
and troops just hanging out there quite
literally digging in the trenches and
now all suffering from radiation
sickness or what might be called
radiation poisoning uh the daily beast
reports the troops who reportedly dug
trenches in a contaminated red forest
near the site of the worst nuclear
disaster in history are now being
treated in a special medical facility in
gamel belarus the forest is so named
because of thousands of pine trees that
turned red
during the nuclear disaster the area is
considered so highly toxic that not even
highly specialized chernobyl workers are
allowed to enter the zone
local reports suggest
seven buses with the zapped troops
arrived in gamel earlier thursday
journalists on the ground have also
reported ghost buses of dead soldiers
being transported from belarus to russia
under the cover of dark
i can't help but imagine how
when every time something bad happens to
the russian army
because of
either their own incompetence or just
the irrational and irresponsible nature
of what they're being directed to do by
putin and putin's generals
putin is certainly giving some different
story to his people in russia it must be
ukraine's fault it's the west fault it's
this that the other the other hand this
nuclear
um
poisoning
a radiation poisoning episode
is emblematic of the entire
invasion of ukraine a bad idea from the
start
stupid and unnecessary
and complete and total disregard for
life whether it's ukrainian life or
russian life just complete and total
disregard for life and that's that's
sort of like the doctrine of the russian
military let's just throw bodies at a
problem
and either the problem will go away or
the bodies will go away
and uh at least recently there's a lot
of bodies here that are going away
absolutely horrible and uh
again this is
not to take the the idea here is not oh
the poor russian troops although it is i
mean the truth is a lot of these russian
troops
now know they were lied to about even
the context into which they were being
sent they were lied to about the mission
they were lied to about why they were
going to ukraine in a sense they are
many of them kids 19 18 years old
victims of disinformation propaganda
that that is an aspect of this but
really the story is not to say who has
been more victimized it's obviously been
ukraine it's the sheer
disregard for human life and safety that
is the status quo
of the decisions made by putin and his
generals i don't know how much longer
it's going to go yesterday on the bonus
show we had a longer conversation about
the supposed withdrawal from keeve which
russians are saying oh we're doing that
in order to foster good faith peace
talks at the same time as the troops on
the ground withdrew from kiev
the amount of air bombardment increased
so it may have been as simple as russia
getting some of its people out of harm's
way before increasing the bombing we
really don't know what's going on and uh
we're going to continue covering the
story of course
so listen there is an investigation into
joe biden's son hunter biden that is
reportedly going on and i i really want
to speak to
either the progressives in the audience
in the sense that for months really
almost for years now
the right and republicans and the
trumpian right has been talking about
hunter biden's laptop hunter biden's
laptop hunter biden's criminality joe
biden's criminality linked to hunter
biden and we have taken each story one
at a time and each claim one at a time
and said here's the lies here's the lies
here's the lies i've also said before
that if hunter biden maybe did something
wrong
he should be investigated and unlike
donald trump
joe biden shouldn't try to interfere
with that investigation joe biden
shouldn't try to
affect or influence that investigation
in any way
and if hunter biden has committed a
crime he should be charged
and if he is convicted he should be
punished this is a very different
perspective than that of the trumpian
right which is obfuscate
obstruct
influence and try to affect legal
proceedings so we should be consistent
and that's exactly what i'm going to be
first of all i'm not going to hide from
you that it now appears there is a
federal investigation into hunter biden
big report yesterday from cnn federal
investigation of hunter biden heats up
now it has nothing to do with the laptop
may be disappointing to some republicans
in our audience cnn reports a justice
department investigation into hunter
biden's business activities has gained
steam in recent months with a flurry of
witnesses providing testimony to federal
investigators and more expected to
provide interviews in the coming weeks
according to multiple sources familiar
with the matter okay
what are the origins or oranges of this
investigation well the probe led by the
u.s attorney in wilmington delaware
began as early as 2018
and it concerns multiple financial and
business activities in foreign countries
dating to when joe biden was vice
president
investigators have examined whether
hunter biden and some of his associates
associates violated money laundering tax
and foreign lobbying laws as well as
firearm and other regulations these are
that's a serious investigation
hunter biden has not been charged with
any crimes has denied wrongdoing his
father president joe biden is not being
investigated as part of the probe of his
son's business activities according to
sources who have been briefed but the
ongoing investigation has persistently
raised questions about the ethics and
behavior of the president's son and has
fueled right-wing political attacks in
2019 then president trump pressured
ukraine to investigate the bidens over
hunter's work for burisma
a ukrainian energy company eventually
leading to trump's first impeachment
so
guys
let's just allow this to happen right i
mean investigate
do whatever you need to do
i don't care about hunter biden as in in
terms of you know as a political program
in terms of political analysis
unlike jared kushner
unlike ivanka trump
unlike so many of trump's cronies
hunter has nothing to do with joe
biden's administration hunter has
nothing to do with policy hunter's not
sitting in for the secretary of state
the way ivanka was at the g20 or
whatever meeting it was i have no
interest in defending hunter biden
there's nothing linking joe biden to any
of this hunter biden is being
investigated for things he did as a
private citizen if he did something
wrong then charge the guy if you want to
throw the book at him throw the book at
him if he's found guilty of any crimes
we shouldn't apply a different standard
now at the same time it's worth
remembering
that what's going on with hunter biden
reinforces
that what appears to be the trump crime
family should be investigated
and we continue to wonder
what's going on what's going on
manhattan investigators quitting because
they got the impression that even though
they found evidence of trump felonies
not trump's kids trump felonies that no
charges were forthcoming i told you on
monday or tuesday that a federal judge
has indicated evidence should be
provided
on the basis that it seems likely that
trump committed felonies merit garland
seems to have absolutely no interest in
pursuing any of it so investigate hunter
investigate trump there's evidence of
felonies charge all of them here's a
quick report from cbs news about this
multiple sources tell cbs news that the
federal investigation into hunter
biden's business practices is broader
than previously known
the probe is exploring whether the
younger biden and his associates
violated tax money laundering and
foreign lobbying laws business records
reviewed by cbs news and documents
released by republicans in congress
indicate multiple financial transactions
involving hunter biden his firm and a
chinese energy company called cefc
republicans allege that the company is
an arm of the chinese government
investigate all of it so let's be
consistent guys let's be consistent
everybody who has uh who is suspected of
wrongdoing should be investigated if
he's cleared he will be cleared if he's
not he can be charged that's it and we
need to remember
when we talk about the laptop claims and
rudy giuliani's uh evidence that he has
in his den or whatever when it's wacky
and cartoonish we debunk it separately
there's an investigation going on and it
should and nobody should interfere in it
if you disagree with my perspective let
me know you can find me on twitter
deepakman and i'm glad to follow up on
it
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is a community
supported independent media program i
would love for you to join the ranks of
our supporters and sign up at
joinpackman.com you can not only now
buy a membership you can gift a
membership we currently have about 350
people who would like a membership but
cannot afford one and you can fulfill
the dreams of as many of those as those
350 people as you would like when you go
through the sign up process at
jointpakman.com just click the box that
says this is a gift
leave the recipient blank and we will on
a first come first serve basis uh give
that membership to someone in need you
can also request a free membership at
davidpakman.com
free membership very very exciting stuff
you can also join the discussion with
more than uh close to 35 000 actually of
our viewers and listeners on the david
pakman show subreddit that's at
davidpakman.com
slash reddit
r-e-d-d-i-t
let's look at a few posts from the
subreddit first one from user joey death
says does ukraine realize that a no-fly
zone equals world war three there's
really no way to word this without
throwing shade at the ukrainians but i
keep hearing ukraine and the zelensky
administration calling for a no-fly zone
as i'm sure many of you have as well
there's obviously no happy ending in
store for ukraine but i do wonder if
this is a heat of the moment thing for
them since the no-fly zone and other u.s
nato restrictions can lead to world war
three am i just not seeing it from their
heated perspective so
it
it is both true that a no-fly zone could
well be the trigger for world war three
but you also are not seeing it from the
ukrainian perspective so let's think
think through that
why would a no-fly zone potentially mean
world war three well the the issue with
the no-fly zone is
announcing a no-fly zone
is just an announcement it doesn't
necessarily mean anything
but when you
announce a no-fly zone
you have to enforce the no-fly zone and
what that means is
shooting down planes if they violate the
no-fly zone and it leaves open
the idea that russia could
just violate the no-fly zone with with
um a pilot pipe human pilot piloted
planes
um or send drones to have them
deliberately shot down to then justify
an escalation there's all sorts of
different ways in which the enforcement
of the no-fly zone could indeed lead to
world war iii what you also have to
consider as many of our reddit users uh
made clear
from the perspective of the ukrainians
they are seeing total war from russia
and they recognize that even if they've
been able to resist certain advancements
from russia to some degree
russia's military is absolutely massive
and so although the enforcement of the
no-fly zone
could lead to some deaths
my guess is
the ukrainian calculation is it'll save
a ton of people
in in other words you shoot down a plane
and it lands and the plane crashing
kills a few people but think about how
many ukrainians could be killed if that
plane is able to do bombing sorties
sorties in ukraine so i i think that we
we aren't seeing it from the ukrainian
perspective
and there's also accuracy accuracy to
the no-fly zone enforcement could be
world war iii as of right now
no no-fly zone has been put in place
user hohh
posted to the subreddit is sexism
unavoidable what if a female comedian
delivered the baldness joke at the
oscars would will smith has had slapped
her and then walked away to receive a
standing ovation within minutes yeah i
think this is a fair point
um
and i think that uh it is
inevitable
that the situation was seen the way it
was seen
to some degree because the joke was made
about a woman's hair
and the person telling the joke was male
and the person doing the slapping was
also male now i don't know that it's
sexism necessarily but i think that this
post correctly identifies
that were it you know whitney cummings
or nikki glazer or whoever whatever
female comedian telling that joke about
jada pinkett smith
if will smith goes up and slaps her the
way he slapped chris rock
um
he's certainly kicked out i mean i guess
they tried to kick him out and will
smith just stayed and nobody did
anything about it he's certainly kicked
out if if not arrested i think that's
true i think also there's another aspect
to this which is if the joke had been
made about
a bald man
there likely never would have been a
slap anyway i mean i think there's no
way to to remove gender dynamics from
that situation
that doesn't necessarily make it sexism
and everything that that connotes but
there's no question that gender played a
role in everybody's reaction
um
last post today from early gold who
posted please support the bonus show so
we can get better audio controls yeah
i'm going to play for you there have
been some horrible audio issues plaguing
the live streams lately here's just a
little bit of a of of a reminder for
those who might have been hearing myself
coming back that's weird
are you guys hearing me twice every time
you're not
just wait for it okay let's try now
okay okay let's try now no i still
didn't i'm still hearing myself okay
okay let's try now no i still didn't i'm
still hearing myself okay okay let's try
now no i still didn't i'm still hearing
myself okay okay let's try now no i
still didn't i'm still hearing myself
okay okay let's try now no i still
didn't i'm still hearing myself okay
let's try it out
anyway i won't plague you guys with the
entire thing but that did go on for
about 10 minutes it's not we don't need
a donation to fix that or anything some
people thought david you know maybe we
need to donate to fix your audio no it
was just uh user error that's all it was
but i think we very very soon are going
to have the audio figured out for the
live streams join the discussion on the
subreddit at davidpakman.com
reddit
guys i have to tell you
i am taking pleasure in someone else's
misfortune you know that the the german
term schadenfreude
means pleasure derived by some other
person's misfortune and i admit i am
taking pleasure in the fact that donald
trump's truth social app is collapsing
and has seen a 93
drop in sign ups
since the week that they launched i
don't take pleasure in the illness and
death of others even when those people
are disgusting when rush limbaugh had
lung cancer and died i said listen there
are people who love this guy and while
the globe may be better off with him not
doing his show i don't take pleasure in
illness or death i don't take pleasure
in the job losses of hard-working people
or the breakups of relationships that
are meaningful to others but when you
put up an obvious twitter clone
and you claim that you're doing it
because they're censoring conservatives
on social media and
and then it fails miserably i love it i
absolutely love it this is a great
report from the rap the would-be twitter
killer has drawn only 1.2 million
installations according to sensor tower
former president donald trump's truth
social app
is seeing a 93
drop in sign ups and similarly steep
decline in traffic after a rocky rollout
last month fraught with technical issues
and an extensive waiting list for new
signups to actually use the service
after going live on president's day the
twitter lookalike saw installs decline
by more than 800 000 since its launch
week
installs on the apple app store this
month have fallen to about 60 000 per
week based on early estimates now if
you're like just some amateur app
builder and you're not putting out
something viral or whatever 60 000 app
installs a week really isn't bad we have
the former president of the united
states here channeling all of the
platforms and ability that he has as
well as his children doing it as well as
all sorts of his former staffers saying
this is going to be
god's gift to social media
it's going to dominate and then you open
sign ups and the website can't handle
the traffic initially people are put on
a waiting list then everybody just
forgets about it and doesn't care and
now nobody's even signing up and both
don jr and eric trump over the last 24
hours have tried to promote the app try
to resuscitate it bring it back to life
by posting how they are now on it um
eric trump tweeted yesterday i'm live
come join the party on untruth social
it's also kind of funny that it took
weeks
for eric trump to even get his account
activated so i love this tell me i'm a
bad person for loving this i'm ready for
it but this is a type of misfortune that
i absolutely take pleasure and just
another embarrassing humiliating failure
for the former president and we'll have
screenshots from the app and more
information about this
i call it a glorious failure i really do
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show today we're going to
be speaking with dr balan jalal who's a
researcher at harvard university and
visiting researcher at cambridge
university one of the world's leading
experts on sleep paralysis
it's really great to have you on i
appreciate it
oh i'm glad to be here david
so sleep sleep is such an interesting
field because it seems to me
it's difficult to study it without
affecting one's sleep in the sense that
many of the settings in which sleep is
studied like sleep labs for example
are very unnatural situations to do
something that most of us do every day
which is sleep sleep while being
observed sleep with electrodes on etc it
seems that it's difficult to get great
data for that reason can you talk a
little bit about that is that true
yeah yeah that's true i mean you know
bringing somebody into a sleep lab and
hooking them up with these electrodes
and things like that and having them
sleep in a sleep lap is obviously not as
you know
useful as as the home environment where
you naturally sleep and things like that
so i agree uh it it is difficult but
nonetheless it's it's doable
uh but i agree you know we don't have
that uh so it's a bit of a tricky thing
in that way let's maybe start and talk a
little bit about sleep paralysis now
uh to some degree
in certain phases of sleep we we are
paralyzed in the sense that we might be
dreaming of taking some physical action
and you aren't taking that physical
action in the real world you might be
punching someone in a dream but your
body is not going out and punching into
the air and that's a good thing when it
happens in the in the correct times is
that right
that's right david so each night we
cycle through these 90 states like 90
minute cycles of sleep and if you sleep
eight hours i hope you do then you have
like maybe four of these blocks and
during one of these stages you go
through something called rem sleep and
during rem sleep you have these bizarre
life like crisp dreams you know the ones
where you see yourself on the moon
wrestling with an alligator and then
having tea with the queen everything is
just messed up you know so during these
dreams you certainly don't want to act
these streams out and hurt your sleeping
partner so your brain uh essentially the
lower part of the brain paralyzes your
entire body
and so yeah you have this uh paralysis
each night you know uh that that you you
go through pretty much now when we talk
about sleep paralysis as a as a
phenomena and condition
what we're really talking about is
outside of rem sleep the body remaining
paralyzed
well sleep paralysis is basically this
like so you're in this paralysis state
during this rem stage of sleep and then
suddenly parts of the brain that has to
do with sort of uh sort of wakefulness
centers of the brain cortical region
regions they become prematurely
activated so you start waking up in a
way even though you're still paralyzed
in rem so it's a the synchrony to the
architecture of rem whereby your brain
suddenly switches so it's awake and
sleeping at the same uh you know in the
same way at the same time so you have
this clash of wakefulness and rem
paralysis occurring at the same time so
that what what sleep paralysis is how
common is that
you know about 20 of the population have
experienced sleep paralysis at least one
time but then you have maybe uh one or
two percent that have it more
chronically so they will have sleep
paralysis you know two or three times a
day or a week or you know five or six
times a month so it is really but at
least one uh in in um at least 20
percent have it have had it in one you
know at least once in their life
is it is it a bad thing in the sense of
is it a condition that we that we are we
try to treat i guess is the question
right so if you have it just like a
regular person you have it you know once
or twice in your life and indeed it can
be scary i mean you wake up paralyzed
you think you might you know you're
gonna die perhaps and then there's a
ghost in your room because typically you
have you hallucinate during these
experiences
and so that is terrifying and
frightening but it's not you know
pathological in its own in its own right
right it's just you know scary and
things like that but if you have it
chronically it becomes a parasomnia you
know so it's a fearful
uh thing that keeps occurring in your
life and our research suggests if you
give this too much meaning and you say
this is a demon chasing me i'm being
possessed and things like that which can
occur in certain cultures well then
potentially it could even lead to things
like anxiety and maybe even trauma from
just you know being overwhelmed by by
these paralysis and having these you
know scary hallucinations
let's talk a little bit about
the dream component of sleep
there is so much literature going back
so long with different ideas about dream
meaning and dream interpretation
um
there are
one side is it's completely random
there's no connection whatsoever between
dreams and what's happening in the real
world for you there's another side which
is no that the dreams are a direct
response to
things that are taking place in
someone's life and there can be sort of
specific meaning assigned to them
let's start with maybe some of the
common dream tropes that a lot of people
report so like falling in a dream and
waking up before you hit the ground is a
very common theme
teeth falling out can be another common
one the idea that you're kind of running
or walking but it's almost like you're
in molasses like it's very very
difficult to move you know there's these
common themes that a lot of people seem
to experience so it seems like it would
follow that there must be some meaning
to those at least
absolutely there is a there's a pattern
right so let's take them one by one so
you mentioned the tooth falling out
so that seems to be uh due to sort of
the and so all of us right and at a
certain age when we're children have
teeth literally falling out of our mouth
and imagine this must be very anxiety
provoking so obviously you will lay down
memories of this fear and anxiety that
will remain with you
for many people the rest of their lives
but they can't really you know
pin down like why do i have this dream
why am i terrified of my dreams falling
out well there was a period in our life
where our teeth were you know loose and
we're literally falling out so
yeah so you you lay down these memories
and the memory parts of your brain and
then you will dream about them often
another very common dream is like being
late for an exam even though i mean
you're 40 50 60 you're running your
business but you're dreaming about being
late for an exam right so that's a
common one then you mentioned the dr the
thing where you're trying to you know
run you know you can't get away what's
going on there well it turns out you're
right your dream during rem sleep during
this dream stage of sleep have has a
certain physiology and a certain neural
pattern
and one of these the signatures of this
is that your um the motor part of the
brain sort of the the this part of the
brain that has to do with movement is
sort of is not fueled by the chemicals
it needs to move okay
and uh but the emotional part of the
brain is hyperactive that's a chemical
see the choline and the emotional parts
of the brain are overactive so you have
this clash between your mortar part of
the brain the movement part of the brain
being weakened and then the emotional
part of the brain the instinctual part
of the brain being overactive and that
manifests as as this you this dream
where you are running but you are really
slow right you're in quicksand and then
this monster is chasing you so that is
an example
of that uh and what you mentioned
another one the falling one just falling
and waking up before you know before you
agree yeah i think that's unclear but
probably because we used to drink or
sleep in high places right like trees
and things like that uh so it makes
sense to have reflex of you know being
able to catch yourself before you fall
so perhaps your brain has remnants of
this in its uh your memory centers but
you know in short
your brain has a certain chemistry
during the dream stage right so like
noradrenaline this chemical that allows
us to focus in on being being really
focused is absent during the dream stage
and that means things are like spacey
you can't really focus on a specific
thing but it's more like the world is
bizarre and time is just and places all
warped so that's a signature of that you
know or for example there's no logic or
a coherent story and that's because the
logical part of the brain is not working
so there is this neural signature that
defines what you then see but then you
have memories and things like that which
you will sort of pull in and sort of
color the dream so if you live in a
certain way you will dream about
monsters relevant to your culture so you
have all these elements in fact even
your environment if you're in a cold
room you might you know dream of being
in iceland and you know you know how
you're having a fight with a ice bear or
something you know like with a so so
certainly your environment your
physiology and all that influences your
dream in that way
there are so many um
academic texts and research now about
sleep problems and sleep problems are so
common particularly in western countries
for sure
and there's so many different aspects to
this there's the hypnotic type
medications like ambien and lunesta that
some people take there's the sleep
hygiene aspect of you've gotta you know
get off screens at least an hour before
going to bed don't be doing things in
your bedroom other than sleeping
associate the bedroom with sleep you all
turn lights down there's kind of that
aspect of it there's the more kind of
like natural cures type side which often
involves
herbs or supplements or apple cider
vinegar and kind of all these different
things all of this different stuff
clearly because we recognize that sleep
is important and we do better when we've
slept well is there some kind of
overarching takeaways right now that you
think are the most important when it
comes to getting good sleep
it's a good it's a good question so i
would say sleep at the same time and
wake up at the same time every day your
brain has this biological clock that
really defines when you feel tired and
how you get quality sleep so that's one
thing the light issue is a huge thing
avoid bright light late in the night i
mean we know this but it's very
important to you know stick to this
um you know those are important to
remember stress and anxiety is the key
one i mean if you have stress and
anxiety during the day your brain just
can't turn off you know the emotional
parts of the brain will be overactive
and that will spill over into the you
know sleep state you know into sleep and
will just not allow you to have deep
quality sleep so those are the main
thing um so light
exercise is so easy just exercising
especially you can even do things like
walking you know that will help you get
more deep sleep the stage four before
rem sleep that that's important sort of
for you know growth and uh just
cellular repair and stuff like that so
exercise is a great one
you know i would say those are the main
pillars and also if you can sleep
consistently i mean we did some there's
some we did not but there's some studies
were done over in boston
uh david where they showed that if you
sleep a regular uh amount of hours each
night let's say even six or seven that's
better than sleeping like eight nine and
then six and five and then eight and ten
and so having a regular you know amount
of sleep each night is better than just
you know going crazy and on you know in
the weekends with like 12 hours there
are some people i mean famously donald
trump who says that for his whole life
he's basically only slept about four
hours a night and that that's enough
that he feels fine i know
including from matthew walker's research
that there is a range of what is sort of
like the natural correct amount of sleep
for people but i've not seen anything
empirical that suggests the that the
human body can function properly with an
extended period of four hours a night of
sleep can you talk about that at all are
there people who genuinely are fine with
that amount of sleep
you know i was surprised when i learned
there actually is so there's a genetic
you know mutation in a rare subset of
people so it's very rare it's probably
not you and i david unfortunately
certainly not me but uh there is a rare
breed of people that can sleep four or
five hours so you know and they will
feel rested and they just sleep more
efficiently they have this mutation and
perhaps you know in a you know enough
time we'll all have this mutation if
it's if it's you know
advantageous but certainly there is uh
seems to be this genetic mutation of
people who sleep very little but i was
quite surprised when i learned that this
seems to be the case and there's some
folks in california doing research on
this uh very curious topic yes but it
but it is seems to be true have you
studied a lot or or read a lot about the
idea of the the biphasic sleep schedule
there's this idea that back when we had
to stoke fires in the middle of the
night
um humans would you know sleep three or
four hours be up for an hour or two and
then sleep another three or four hours
and it seems to be the sort of a source
of a lot of debate because on the one
hand
it does appear as though there was a
point at which it would have made sense
based on circumstances but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's a good or
healthy thing to be doing right
i think that research on this is
emerging uh there it could be that
biphasic sleep in the way you mentioned
i mean certainly people used to many
people used to sleep like that you know
with their rituals at night and then go
going back to sleep and it seems like it
could potentially be good that you get
more efficient sleep in that way but the
research i would say is emerging uh
another you know just uh element to this
is also the whole idea of a siesta time
and sleeping during that time and it
seems also there might be a biological
advantage of of doing that the fact that
you will feel tired by noon and sleeping
for those hours could potentially help
and even napping can be very very
refreshing and you know sometimes even
compensate for hours of sleep but i
think the research on that at least for
my knowledge is 100 clear and certainly
not with the biphasic sleep but i
wouldn't i wouldn't rule it out it could
be that it's it's you get more you know
for your no more bang for the buck by
sleeping that way it could be when
you've talked about kind of like the
natural sleep schedules of people
there's quite a bit of research that
throughout our lives
the natural wakefulness and sleepiness
schedule kind of shifts and one of the
big areas of controversy with this is
the time that school starts for
different kids
and when i was in high school the first
class started at 7 35 a.m
which was completely counter to my
natural schedule which was to be up
until 12 30 or 1 in the morning now i
get up far earlier that's a schedule
that now now would work much better for
me is there something to this idea that
much school is starting way too early
absolutely so there's a genetic
component to when you want to fall
asleep you know like there's a chrono
type in terms of like we have our
genetic uh you know preference in terms
of when we want to sleep and want to you
know whether you want to be night owls
or or not and uh so yes for a lot of
people they will just naturally be night
owls they will be inclined to sleep very
late and wake up later and so for those
folks it's it's a problem because you're
starting school that early and you will
exclude these people in that way you
won't have their full uh you know brain
capacity uh you know you'd be using that
so so it is something but i'll say
something i you know in my entire life
david i was i was sleeping maybe at two
or three a.m that's just my natural
thing but the last four years i've been
sleeping at 10 p.m you know so i've
totally shifted how i sleep as well and
it just works better so sometimes even
though you think you're a night owl by
nature you you might in fact be somebody
who's not so no me too i mean i i tried
i also saw this natural shift where
because of my schedule 10 15 and i was
just getting into bed and i thought to
myself i used to kind of be a night owl
let me see what happens if i try to just
stay up a little later and get up a
little later it felt very unnatural
where i was just fine it was a you know
11
and i was just like i should just be in
bed right now this this doesn't feel
like it's my schedule any longer
100 that's what happened to me and i was
surprised and i was i thought i was
genetically just you know doomed to be
somebody who has you know sleep at 3 a.m
but yeah you know i sleep much earlier
and i feel better the the work in the
field is fascinating we've been speaking
with dr balan jalal who's a researcher
at harvard university and also a
visiting researcher at cambridge
university really a pleasure having you
on and i appreciate your time today my
pleasure david
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
so on sunday when i started preparing
our monday show i didn't realize that
this would be the week of the burner
phone where burner phones becomes a
topic just about every single day but it
is and we have hilarious new information
about burner phones and it actually
comes from trump's former national
security adviser john bolton who
appeared on cnn yesterday and said trump
not only used burner phones all the time
he used the term burner phones all the
time so let's back up and kind of give
you the genesis of this entire lie
the first thing that happened was that
we learned that the call logs turned
over to the january 6th trump riot
committee by the trump white house were
missing about seven and a half hours of
calls
and one of the things that was
speculated was well okay they might have
just deleted the records of what
happened on the phones during those
seven and a half hours but also trump
might have been using the phones of
associates during those seven and a half
hours or he might have been using burner
phones these disposable phones that you
use and then you throw away okay trump
first and foremost immediately put out a
statement saying i have no idea what a
burner phone is to the best of my
knowledge i have never even heard the
term
and i immediately told you that seems
like an obvious lie just doesn't really
make any sense that that's not a term
trump would be familiar with
the next day
we got a statement
written statement from john bolton
trump's former national security adviser
to cbs news and the statement was
i heard trump use the phrase burner
phones multiple times
and trump absolutely knows what it means
makes perfect sense it's just not
believable that donald trump doesn't
know what a burner phone is obviously
trump knows and uses the term
but it was just kind of a written
statement we now have an interview of
donald trump's former national security
adviser john bolton on cnn saying he he
used the term all the time and you know
what i believe john bolton and i'll tell
you why in a second take a listen to
this report the house select committee
investigating the january 6th
insurrection is looking into whether
former president trump used so-called
burner phones during a seven-hour gap in
official white house call records during
the riot during the attack on the
capitol in response trump said in a
statement quote i have no idea what a
burner phone is to the best of my
knowledge i have never even heard of of
the term joining us now is former trump
national security advisor john bolton uh
sir what do you say to that
well i i can't understand what the the
former president is uh is saying because
i heard him use the term
burner phone a number of times it's
hardly like it's some obscure highly
classified uh set of words yeah it's not
like key bump about cocaine key bumps
like madison cawthorne used guys
everybody knows what a burner phone is
uh criminal gangs in the united states
use burner phones terrorists around the
world use bone burner phones and as i
say i i heard he mentioned it so you'll
have to you'll have to guess what the
reason for his statement is he said
quote
burner phones in in conversation
he did yes it was a term he actually
kind of liked he'd say you know they
have these burner phones
uh uh
so you know it's uh the president former
president's uh acquaintance with the
truth is often very casual i think
bolton's telling the truth guys i mean
listen bolton is a terrible warmongering
neocon but he's clearly the more
trustworthy one here first of all logic
tell us trump's constant logic tells us
trump's constantly
first of all trying to hide records of
the things that he's doing is it likely
that the term burner phone has never
come up in his trying to hide records of
the things that he does secondly trump's
constantly talking about gang activity
in the united states undocumented
immigrants trafficking ms-13 etc do we
whatever your opinion is about trump's
view on immigration do we really believe
that the term burner phones hasn't been
regularly used in trump's discussions
with officials about immigration and
gangs and so on it's just not believable
and as horrible a person as john bolton
is architect of the iraq war i mean
horrible horrible guy
in this particular disagreement
it's very clear who's telling the truth
by the way this is kind of funny too
there's even a picture now that has been
found
where it looks like trump
has a potential burner phone with him
there's these pictures and we're showing
one to our audience where trump has
phones wrapped in newspapers when he's
getting on and off the golf course and
again the speculation is this is a
really weird way to carry a phone that
these are phones trump is handed to make
individual phone calls and then they're
just given back to whoever wrapped up in
the newspaper and thrown into the trash
that's speculative that's speculative
but there are a number of these pictures
so why does it matter well it matters
because as usual trump is lying about
everything down to the absolute smallest
detail that's why we care about it
that's why it matters and uh he's lying
when it comes to hiding his phone
activity on january 6th he's lying when
it comes to what he was doing during
that time and his motivations and his
reaction his opinion about what happened
on january 6th and he's obviously lying
about the little things as well like
burner phone i don't know i've never
heard of that that that's never it's
quite frankly
it's like a cocaine user
saying
i don't know what a key bump is i've
never that's never that's not a term
i've ever heard come on guys it's just
not believable and we are not
rehabilitating john bolton's image we
are not doing anything other than saying
in this particular case
it's obvious to me
that bolton's the guy that's telling the
truth
is disney
trying
to make children
gay
you might say david that's the stupidest
thing i've ever heard even the concept
aside from disney how do you make
someone gay and i would say to you yeah
i know it doesn't make any sense this is
the new
cultural flashpoint of the week on
right-wing media fox business and others
are i guess trying to start moral panic
by arguing
that a recent leaked video from an
internal disney conference call of sorts
meeting of sorts
is evidence that disney is actively
trying to make kids
gay or lgbtq
fox business with the report
disney exposed
leaked videos show officials you have to
do the alex jones voice when you read
something like this leaked videos show
officials pushing lgbt agenda
saying desantis wants to erase gay kids
charlie kirk
right wing
individual
charlie kirk claims disney is trying to
make your children gay
why else would you want to have two
dudes or two women kissing in a disney
film
okay
what is this all related to this all
relates to
um a
video
from a disney all hands meeting about
the florida don't say gay bill
and in this meeting
executive producer latoya raveno
says that her team has implemented a not
all seek not at all secret gay agenda
now you've got to listen to the video to
actually understand what she's talking
about so let's do that this is the
source of the moral panic about disney
it's trying to make your kids gay it's
like i love disney's content i grew up
watching you know all of the classics
they have been a huge like informative
part of my life but at the same time
like i worked at small studios most of
my career and i heard you know hear
whispers like i heard things like oh you
know they won't let you show this at a
disney show and i'm like okay so i was a
little like sus when i started and but
then
my experience was bafflingly the
opposite of what i had heard on my
little pocket of like you know proud
family disney tva um
the showrunners were super welcoming
meredith roberts and like the our
leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda and so like
how dare she
but what does she actually mean i i feel
like
i felt like it was i mean like maybe it
was that way in the past but i guess
like something must have happened in the
last like like they were turning it
around they're going hard and then
all that like momentum that i felt like
that
sense of i don't have to be afraid to
like
let's have these two characters kiss
let's in the background this like i was
just wherever i could just basically
adding queerness to like if you see
anything queer in the show
but like okay so you could be like whoa
that's a really weird way of explaining
what you're doing that that's very
strange but it's abundantly clear that
she's not talking about making people
gay what she's talking about is she has
an agenda to show
lgbtq characters represented in disney
stuff it's not like that big of a deal
even many sort of like centrist
companies recognize that hey you know in
like commercials maybe or wherever
in the same way that at one point it
became very end vogue to show like
interracial couples or just uh um
non-white parents in commercials we we
you know 10 12 years ago that was a big
thing
the same thing is now being done to be
more representative when it comes to
content like on disney and the idea that
this is them trying to make kids gay is
just the latest version of moral panic
here's the charlie kirk clip listen to
how he interprets this
it's i know i keep resorting back to it
but christopher caldwell really depicted
the danger
of having out of control liberation
movements that are not anchored in
legitimate grievance
christopher caldwell in the book age of
entitlement warned us that the
trajectory that we are on is the very
groups that allegedly want liberation
will soon become the tyrants themselves
in fact it will happen almost
immediately almost overnight
that once the groups
are formed it's not like all of a sudden
the aclu
and the lgbt groups like disassemble
like oh we got gay marriage done now we
can just put our paperwork away no it's
an entire cottage industry of outrage
and hysteria it gave them meaning and
purpose and so now it's just that's not
about making gay marriage legal it's
legal in every single state
that was always their big fight no now
it's about making your kids gay
why don't no why else would you want to
have two dudes or two women kissing in a
disney film what is it maybe because
that exists in the real world then you
want to be representative of the real
world charlie the agenda to expose them
to it or to increase the ranks of the
lgbtq community
what is the process
people were gay
before this sort of
nonsense was happening so why exactly
are you doing this
and of course the answer's so simple
that that it's just to represent the way
the real world is
don't they get the idea is we're just
going to represent that in the world
there's different types of people it's
sort of like i mean apply it
we were doing fine when every actor was
white and in order to have a black
character
a white actor would use blackface that
was fine why did we need to bring in
black actors well because there's black
people in the real world right i mean
that's
isn't it sort of obvious and the idea of
making people gay is of course absurd
and you all will understand that there
is nothing i could say
to my gay friends
to make them no longer gay
and in fact
when
gay people see movies in which
heterosexual couples kiss
it doesn't make them heterosexual
okay and similarly
there's nothing anyone could say to me
or show me a video of
that would then make me gay i mean it's
just a it's a ridiculous commentary it's
an absurd commentary the funniest clip i
saw on this was from newsmax where
newsmax host said
you know movies are just about people
why do they have to be about lgbt people
well that's exactly why because lgbt
people exist in the world and they're
people too it's very very strange the
the level of uh
reflexive homophobia that comes out
i don't get this be your whole self
routine at work or even in art even in
products that you are creating for other
people to consume
for instance take me
i love model trains did you know that i
actually do
these guys they've got a great train set
i've admired it i've helped i i love
trains i love them
i don't talk about it on tv because it's
a pretty niche hobby and not a lot of
people are into it all right especially
at my age
being gay isn't a hobby by the way i
don't know i mean this is really crazy
that's my thing i'll do it on my time
and i'm not gonna bother you about it
fair you get it i think that's a pretty
good analogy this is sick it's not a
good analogy it's not a good analogy
then there's this
the showrunners were super welcoming
meredith roberts and like the our
leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda i don't have to be
afraid to like
let's have these two characters kiss
let's in the background like i was just
wherever i could just basically adding
queerness to like if you see anything
queer that you come around them but like
i just was like no one would stop me and
no one was trying to stop me
just have fun with your not so secret
gay agenda and queerness and putting it
in movies and cartoons and uh where has
it been so far
i watch this stuff from time to time i
guess over the years these are movies
you've heard of i've heard of
is this what they've been up to all
along is this what they will be up to
from now on
um i don't think it's going to help the
plot line
you know movies are about people why do
they have to be about lgbtq people or
anything like is the orientation really
all that well
lgbtq people exist in the world
so you would expect to see them in the
movies a very difficult concept and this
is the latest moral panic
it's bs be aware of it it's not going to
stop anytime soon hey this voicemail i
have to play for you today is really
emblematic of the sort of arrogance that
we now see among many on the right this
is a caller named juan who used to call
in and say he was the anti-intellectual
now he just says it's juan
and it turns out juan realized he knows
more than his doctors this this is
without a shred of irony guys take a
listen to this
hey david it's me again juan right
health care is a scam
anecdotally most of the doctors that
i've had to deal with are ignorant
and i've had to correct them several
times so anecdotally and maybe you're
dealing with the wrong doctors juan
and
at the end of
my interaction with them
they've ended up agreeing with me
uh
they have no clue
they have a set of
knowledge
and ideas in their in their minds
that they learned in school
in college and university right
but there's a lot of research
that is a lot more up to date
than what they think now of course any
good doctor is staying up to date on the
research of course and in my experience
when i mentioned to a doctor hey you
know i recently read about x whether
it's in dermatology or whatever they say
oh yeah yeah yeah i'm familiar with that
so the idea that doctors know less than
juan because they go based on what they
learned in medical school 5 10 20 30
years ago but juan is doing internet
research
this is this is the height of the type
of arrogance that got us the ivermectin
stuff
nebulizing hydrogen peroxide etc
uh
i think healthcare needs to be abolished
and totally built from the ground up
so anyway listen guys we're up against
some pretty serious stuff and with not a
shred of irony confidently juan saying
the fact that he looked stuff up on the
internet
and
knew more than his doctors i guess is
evidence that
the medical field is bad i mean it it's
it's crazy it's really really crazy and
this is what we're up against we've got
a great bonus show for you today joe
biden is facing a squeeze on defense
spending from the left and from the
right it's very interesting politically
what's going on
tennessee is trying to find a loophole
in order to be able to ban same-sex
marriage the problem is they might
legalize child brides in so doing it's
bonkers what's going on there and we'll
talk about alex jones facing jail time
at this point all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpacman.com to get instant
access go to davidpakman.com free
membership to request a free membership
and anybody who wants can gift
memberships to others
by checking the this is a gift box when
signing up at
joinpacman.com i will see you then